[Music]
global warming evokes a religious
passion particularly among the secular
left not merely because it
coincidentally justifies every policy
goal they've Harvard for a century but
even more because it offers atheists the
satisfaction of their natural religious
longings climate change is unfalsifiable
as evidenced by the ever-changing
nomenclature global cooling global
warming the catch-all climate change and
now Al Gore's even more me play mouthed
climate crisis this quasi religion
offers sin in pollution redemption in
recycling even the sale of indulgences
in carbon offset credits fantasies of
imminent carbon induced Armageddon are
secular eschatology and Al Gore is a
modern-day millerite but st. Allen his
apostles would do well to ask themselves
a sobering question how would you really
enter life if the world doesn't actually
need your saving I'm Michael Nolt this
is the first episode of the Michael Nolt
show come back tomorrow we'll do it
again
[Music]
you
[Music]